mission control is currency the limits
if you go get some sort of stuff and if
he letters you that from those on behalf of the
russian federation i understand
naomi half of the russian federation
ocean exist there is wreaths mr meijer
so you verkerk and so on
marshal and denim help  from age
rewind how to go home school girls
cohen jehoram
chunk and lead their existence is that
correct
fleur and intact fine my lead and
look behind yes yes the faces
seem knowledge not necessarily bed is the
park retirement you have my  braces yoga sister
de justice who passes sites heitink
your hearts of as uploaded syntra photo
for you out zipper of both clothes and
sewell it's also have on our website
he follows absolutely role of the
powerpoint presentation call the scout
yeah clothes will there is
sites her  magritte you will see how
longer i live of
and then i will return to this costs of
to beautiful mens how long you think you
mean for the possible
enormous citations in h  uis eye wish you
represent
and ben there is a letter fairphone reply
and region north miami can often
explain beltshire and smart
the flora is followed was a sedation
museums yes how the be right before us
rbdjan the
much response is cheating found for
net a  sms voicemail and baby pinkie pie
says touch touch find their is or something
and space for me to show german
family tent medical error driver
lodging parelli computer had again
aware I do have work has a moment to
introduce
resting poverty female interviewer
sire you see you have chi minh  the
established so paper and have your name is
astrid also get an answer
yes international of course so
source product is and he suffered as much fun
as i end an at bat
who told you the defense in the
quarrels earlier no wear yourself
afterwards  a crazy rush a super
slow jerk off reply glamorous
to speak
briefly ms jiang fitz in training
the frisbee in Hoogerwaard colleg  e
first a few comments of a
review will not play never cling
to via treat to this shirt
indeed 20 this would be the leg i
must that they go home that new regime 5 to
diana in the council
to take centers at in  your
writing run dicky is great in the
written notes and haarlem c3
is one to which a tissue as
experiencer flesh and no stress in tier i
get em tearing his limits with red
loosen up the not go for
i want you sometimes more fruit shoot here
again  short in size
success to change who see you appear on
the picture you can't see that fits
elephants leaked no because for whom
i download ios police on the screen
then the in two me playboy so
then i have them on the screen  so myself is
also a sister sorry ladies pringle
watercolor white years on help i'm looking for a
chapter how if you go to the
window
and read through i something like that
old format innovation and sewer be
speaking to new h  head trainer sleazy
about a special go down chatting now
is a few years of life with
the smell you can be ah 20 country is
all tour guide please also of 200 such
an and enlarge the three I am talking about
creation country say differently because of the
riots in the  rest in labor
that you think can shift in that he is
intxausti september [ __ ] seth in ten
years about this ksst careful and
benevolent
and that an open
debate should also be conducted we can drive
my comment now stands in that sign the
russian appeal in cassation and  the case
file is
unusually large and that puts a heavy burden on
the package and on your counsel but we
strongly urge you to
carefully and sympathetically
study everything your complaints including the
sources cited
the case is too important to  with only
the triptych' suffice,
so money does not only apply in the light of
the unimaginably high compensation
for which Russia stands  60
billion antelope brother dollars, but
honest, accurate experts and
benevolent review are especially required
for correcting what we believe
to be correct ict the
arbitral tribunal and the incorrect
reasoning
with which the Hague court has wanted to
fix it if the four core values that I hav
just described  mentioned in connection with the
large size of the case
file that the advocate general and
your council need more study time
than the usual time, but
say then the russian
federation will gladly agree in advance
for weak your council will not be
distracted  due to the many fundamental
and open differences of views
that keep the
netherlands and
slant divided, the case has nothing
to do with, for example, I would call it
an elephant in the room
terrible fate of the MH17
passengers or the affiliation of the
shrinkage with the russian federation
this appeal in cassation is largely
determined by pure r  legal questions in
particular but not only about the explanation of
the ict
the predictable in ship green shoots
of ave
we waited for their first term
to address the russian president and the
russian president we may
not influence the answer to that legal question
the outcome of this  case is
also of great importance for future
recite arbitrations
of nog and already had a major
new against netherlands in the paper
moreover your decision will
affect the much larger currently
tumultuous terrain of the isds
i understand my client's concerns
well  and that arise from the
unsatisfactory way in which the court
rejected your argument in russian
and i say it out loud also on the
suspension request it was rejected by your council
in that suspension case you council was bound
by article 1066 let you know that you have very
effectively  explained in this
main issue, there is fortunately no
longer any room for a merely provisional,
extremely marginal assessment  g and now the
first part that I discuss that is
part 2 3 summarized as no
replacement of a competent ground
and this part
the subpart is directed against the
decision of the court where that
sometimes happens
the court motivated its judgment with the
reference  to suppa of 1007 is
rigid allowed a legal action the
nullification bad and not this
arbitrator ultimately determines whether
the arbitral tribunal is competent
according to the court it would also be difficult to
accept if the
nullification law should nullify an arbitral
award and I
quote only because and in  the pleading memorandum
supports this
only because the arbitral tribunal has based itself on an
incorrect motivation for
how it does what it does,
moreover, according to the
court of appeal, such a correction would be given to the
annulment,
the effectiveness of the arbitral
procedure should serve these three judgments
are all three incorrect and I lie
so far  the court and the court share
the view of russia that the door
the arbitral tribunal accepts
jurisdiction was correct and if
an arbitral tribunal
has based its jurisdiction on an incorrect ground
then the judge must of course annul the arbitral award on
demand
that is not a matter of  a faulty
reasoning of the arbitral tribunal
the judge may only check the correctness of
the basis of that we will review your
and wrote there really has jurisdiction has
diminished
this legal view of russia has been
supported by the court in the verdict
a quo and by carrying out a motivated
expert report  of Professor
Snijders in the most authoritative
knowledge of Dutch process and
arbitration law If an arbitral tribunal
has declared itself incompetent
, the court may not review that judgment either,
which is stated in Article 1052 paragraph 5
and that does not
alter that  a valid
arbitration agreement z  ou may
exist, the judge may not test that,
the advice is yours, as the
professors, among others, argued,
that the right of access to the
court in the proceedings is not protected by
article 17 of the constitution and
title 6 of the ECHR and this applies equally  so in a
case such as this in which the arbitral tribunal has
jurisdiction has accepted at a
court according to Russia and the or incorrect ground
the annulment of such an erroneous arbitral
award after all reflects that access to
ordinary law and
accordingly article 1052 paragraph 4 that only  the
positive decision
with which jurisdiction is accepted by the
arbitral tribunal
can be contested for the AIDS
rights and that in accordance with 1064
and 1065 andy control can by nature
be linked by the
unsuccessful party in the arbitration procedure
here is here
there is no question in this particular remedy of any kind of
incidental grievance or counterclaim of the
winner  Arrangements in the arbitration
from the system of Dutch
arbitration follow that,
contrary to what the Court of Appeal did, one may not deduce from the provisions
under a of 1065 paragraph 1
that the destruction contains bad
errors and errors accepted by the arbitral tribunal already ground at the request of
the removal may  replace
the court may only and only at the
request of the
claimant accept the by the fart inscription
authorized to review the entire ground for correctness in
other words that investigation into a
valid arbitration agreement is
limited to the correctness of the
basis indicated by the ship's law and then
the  appeal of the court to
serve the effectiveness
of the arbitral procedure with such a reparation
your advice has already been decided before, so in
comparison that the judgment in which your
arbitrator has applied an incorrect
standard of assessment
may not be repaired
the same applies to an arbitral tribunal
violated the adversarial
principle  and
the sincere conviction of
the judge that
without those errors the arbitral tribunal would have reached the same
result should not be allowed to
proceed
in conclusion, I would like to point out that
part 2 3 also contains a
subsidiary ground for annulment that has not been discussed above
, it would be a
violation of the right  maintain procedural order
if ave as the defendants in the
nullification procedure as is happening now
is only for the first time b the mori
of grievances
12 years after they have started the arbitration come
up with the new ground
to substantiate the jurisdiction of the arbitral tribunal
that such a  create unacceptable contrasts
with the
restrictions applicable to Russia in
this 1052 paragraph 2 and mirror image
1065 li-2, in
other words due process
requires both parties to discuss
all potentially relevant
powers of
theses as soon as possible and the success of this
part must lead to  the immediate and
destruction of both such judgments
as  s of the yukos towards there is
nothing to refer here
I now like to share mysteries with each other
that mister church
the upward rollercoaster lecture according to
dutch arbitration law and
international law that the choice
for arbitration must be
voluntarily unambiguous and without
reservation
that applies in  in particular also with
regard to sovereign states
one cannot and should not assume that
a state waives its immunity
from jurisdiction,
which is apparent from the settled
case law of your council, among other things, the
international court of justice and the
european court of human rights has
the court that  still misunderstood for a month
by ruling that the requirement of
clear and unambiguous
consent has already been met so much
on the basis of the text of Article 26
ict Although Article 26 ect
concerns an arbitration clause,
it does not appear from this whether the
conditions stated therein are
also met in this case  is satisfied,
moreover, and I will get to that in
detail in a moment  back a russian
federation did not agree to that clause
after all, after all, it did not ratify the treaty
how should Belgians have done here the
european court of human rights
recently ruled on a case in which
a choice of court clause
had been interpreted differently by three authorities
and  the court concluded on this basis that
it was not sufficiently clear that the state concerned
had waived burundi's immunity in this case
you see the relevant legal consideration
in the pleading note and this case
plays exactly the same
the arbitral tribunal the court and the
court gave up  all core questions about
jurisdiction a different answer
to the written explanation is also
a table added in which you can see that the
jurisdiction track is different from a country on at least
ten or so points
and for that reason alone
unambiguous agreement is also lacking in this case
with arbitration
I will explain here to one of those
three colleges that I just mentioned were
right it concerns the
court of the hague
article 26e ct is also depicted on the slide
expressly only provides
for arbitration with regard to disputes
between an investor and a
contracting party
and this is where things actually go wrong  the
russian federation
has signed but not
ratified the treaty
it is not a contracting party within
the meaning of articles 1
and 26 ect the treaty has never
entered into force for it
the russian federation does not need to apply
the arbitration provision provisionally either
article 45  After all, paragraph 1 stipulates that the
treaty must only be
applied provisionally insofar as this provisional
application does not conflict with
national law and regulations.
You can see the text of Article 45, paragraph 1
on the site.
and the thought is the
rationale
behind such determinations  always
the same and the democratic constitutional state
must be respected in the sovereign powers
of parliament
the provisional application of a treaty
that deviates from a formal law
is at odds with the principle
of the separation of powers, in
other words a minister who
signs a treaty
may not  step into the powers of
his or her own
parliament
that is why article 45,
as you see it here on the slide,
was generally accepted at the time that
no signatory
would apply the arbitration provision provisionally,
this has
been confirmed in writing, for example, by the
chairman of the  working group that drew up the
first draft text of the
treaty you see the quote in the
pleading note is entirely in my mind with
this the court of the hague has explained the behavior
in a good way and the
arbitral awards annulled oat
drugs explanation is also closely related to that
of representatives  of many state  n
who commented on this at the time
in the documents also in factual
bodies reference was made, among other things, to
statements of the finnish government
dutch officials japanese
representative a statement from
italy and a minister from the united
kingdom
illustrative is also the joint
statement issued at the time of the
signature was made by the
european commission the european council and
all the then egi member states and
it is stated in Dutch
that article 45 paragraph 1
does not create any obligation that
goes beyond what is
compatible with existing
internal law we will become a commission for
international law of  the united
nations has
convened several meetings in recent years on the subject of the
provisional application of treaties published 2
years ago
as a result of this
draft guidelines
that contain discussions and the
as well as the response from states
to them  These
are a good representation of the
existing rules of international
law and they also confirm the correctness
of the court's explanations and explanations
which, moreover, have been defended from the outset by the
Russian Federation.
By way of example, I refer to the
very recent reactions of  germany and the
netherlands the dutch response
also related to a report from the
advisory committee on issues of international law
you are undoubtedly familiar with that
committee, which consists of 10
renowned
experts in the field of
international law, including,
for example, four professors from uva
your city utrecht and the  university
lead
these experts who
explicitly concluded that those draft guidelines from
the commission and international law of
the united nations
support and you see the quote in the
pleading note for the decision of the
court of the hague of 20 april 2016 and
that ruling amounts to according to
this  committee that it is necessary  to examine for
each individual article in the
treaty whether that provision is
compatible with the national law
of that signatory
the interpretation of the court is also
generally shared in the literature
that
book was not brought into dispute and also
did not invoke the last edition
thereof, but the Court of Appeal has
apparently consulted it and
quoted it many times in the final judgment, but a passage
is ignored by the doll and that is
exactly the massage that deals with the
interpretation of article 45 ec
t and that passage makes it clear that the
interpretation of the court and not that of
the court is correct according to these authors
you have to look at the concrete'
obligations arising from the
treaty
where did it go wrong in this case
haven he  have in the arbitrations and
innovative
treaty they explain that leads they
argued that every sign
in begi  nsel should provisionally apply the treaty in its entirety
,
this is also called the all-or-nothing
explanation,
the arbitral tribunal has adopted an
explanation and a german researcher who
wrote the result about this, he said
yes, but that explanation also included
it was once never defended before the dispute
in the literature
in the judiciary
or in the travaux préparatoires and that
explanation was rightly expressed by the court and later also
by the court what
happened then
master told me that after 12
years  for the first time in the
appeal of this nullification
procedure, people also litigate with yet another new
interpretation and this again concerns an explanation
that was never defended in the literature prior to the dispute between the
parties was
never defended in the case law or
in the travaux préparatoires
this new interpretation differs from that
of the arbitral tribunal, but leads
to more or less the same conclusion as
most contracting states
according to that explanation, they would have
been obliged to provisionally apply the entire treaty
as most of them have just explained to me, the court has wrongly included that new explanation in the assessment, as most of them have just
explained to me,
and
then also acted as if those recently
devised explanations had always been the only
correct interpretation of the treaty  would have
been I need not only scan the text
of article 45
but also the everything we determine ratio the
core ideas underlying
it the importance of the separation of powers
the importance of ratification by
parliament the explanation of the court
has far-reaching  consequences
government leaders most of them
would have entered into more far-reaching obligations according to the explanation by
signing,
namely
to apply the entire treaty
provisionally and that would mean that
most government leaders would
have acted in violation of their own constitutional
powers
that is not the case  and that explanation of
the court that h  has very far-reaching
consequences not only for the interpretation of
this treaty
but also of other treaties with
similar provisions
the court of appeal has also based its conclusion on a
subsidiary argumentation
the court finds that the provisional
application of article 26 is not inconsistent
is with russian law in the
written explanation this is discussed in
detail
then for example the
doctrine of the separation of powers the
court ruled correctly that
provisional application in this case is
contrary to the russian constitution of
this is how the separation of powers starts
After all, just as elsewhere, the Commission entails
that the executive is not entitled
to unilaterally deviate from federal
laws laws passed
by parliament that it appears that
constitutional provisions federal
laws the legislative history the literature
and also established case law of the highest
courts, including, for example,  the
supreme court the constitutional court
, however, you can leave reasons for complaints
about foreign law to be discussed
because that
subsidiary argument rests in its
entirety and also very explicitly if you
take the rest
on a treaty explanation in particular
the interpretation of the words
note in consiste contradictory
and  This again concerns a new
treaty interpretation and interpretation that
has been argued for for the first time on appeal
and in all those various considerations
that apparently concern
Russian law,
the incorrect treaty is assumed time and again,
in other words the court of appeals  the
wrong question about international
law and arrives at an incorrect and
unusable answer about the russian
lay this is therefore a matter
of treaty interpretation
law in the sense of 79 euros the court
unknown in essence also that this
arbitration
the day before the signing  under quarrels
law would have been
impossible impossible on the basis of the national  The law
and regulations,
but the court measures in one way or another
that signing and signing would
have resulted in
treaty obligations nevertheless having
arisen that go beyond and deviate
from national law and that treaty
their interpretation is incorrect and incompatible
again with, for example, the view
of the commission the council and all responding
member states that article 45 paragraph 1 does not
create any obligation that
goes beyond what is
compatible with the existing internal
legal order in
short
the russian federation has not ratified this treaty
it has not agreed to arbitration
the primary  and subsidiary treaty
explanation from the court that are as you see
it on the slide yes they
deviate from what the rest of the
world thinks that explanation must be
destroyed and most meijer will discuss the end
of the
plea on the  need
to submit brady cial questions to the Court of Justice in this context as well,
more the presidency  ter and members of the Supreme
Court more than the card general
I now come to the discussion of the
third part, which concerns the
question of whether there is therefore an
investor in and an investment
on the basis of Article 26 of the ECTS
arbitration is only possible if there
is an investment by an
investor in another contracting state
cross-border, so the question of whether
someone is investing and whether the transaction he has
carried out is an investment can also
be answered
at the time that investment is
made,
the Russian oligarchs have  through
Russian companies controlled by them and you see that
in that picture I wide and above but of course you
look down
so those Russian companies
acquired the Russian Te Yukos
at fake auctions in Russia and that
happened partly by paying more
than 600  13 million dollars in
bribes to the then
official yukos management the
so-called  e law that rectus you are already
encountering in the document
that acquisition was therefore an exclusive
russian domestic transactions on
such a domestic transaction the ect is
in any case not applicable
after all ict only refers to investment in the
territory of another
contracting state
border crossing
your  Advocate General Zoutman Zekaart
confirmed this once again in a recent Opinion
and the most important
passage of his Opinion, which is
noted in the written pleading note,
was confirmed even more recently during
the hearing before the Grand
Chamber of the European Court of Justice in Luxembourg
in the case  moldova can stroy
we were present at the session
there is
also a statement of this in the
written explanation and that case
was about questions that were asked by
the parisian floor table and
was drawn up there noted by
we recorded from the mouths  from
the german represent the dispute
monasteries art  ikel 26 is tony activate it
when there is the dispute between en in
westerwal contracting party ant and other
contracting party
to that domestic newspapers character
of that acquisition of the you cost
shares is not changed by
moving between companies as
hve
professor short arie has
step  described step by step that the
russian oligarchs replaced corner cabinet
shares through an extensive network of
sham companies on
paper eventually to hve
and have that in the picture try to
visualize it below you see that network of
all that company you and dear to
those shares have been transferred  and that
happens a number of times that are
transferred further a total of 67 times
in 21 entities have been
involved and then that little structure is set up
next to it on the right side of your
screen with hvv and that
gibraltar company gm clear above
and there they become that  is then the last
step
to that  len in
yukos and for our status this
structure
this shifting with these yukos shares
happened to disguise that those russian
oligarchs were still the only ones who
had control over those
shares and who were also economically
entitled to those shares and that
they just  did they therefore have via that u
bend via ave
it happened because to that control
so continue to fulfill but also to
be able to evade dividend tax on cyprus
that on balance between sliding
of that of port in me that
did not change the domestic nature of
the original acquisition  by the
russian oligarchs of the yugos
shares
hve that existed only on paper there
will be no business activities there will be
no employees there will be no office and
would not even letterbox
they have not shown
to have paid anything for the yukos shares
they were only their  concealing front of
pretense companies that did not
invest abroad  On the basis
of the wording, rs are the object and
purpose of the ect, a sham
company cannot be an investor either,
according to the state.
there
is also not recognized and sham
companies such as hve are not
regarded as investments in the literature
, the abuse of the ect through letterbox companies has also been pointed out
and
ave does not even know they are letterbox
companies yet because they have sings
during the recent bowl sprinkle session
at  the court of justice has also
confirmed that letterbox companies
cannot be regarded as investments
and that also follows from the
explanation of the european
commission when clarifying the
ect
and under and invested must also be in
his home country cyprus and people in this
case, therefore,
have developed entrepreneurial activities in order to become an investor
and considered
this position of the european commission
is endorsed by all i your member
states and by other ect states
and invested must be in his home country
engaged in substance is
therefore activities and that does
not you hv he does not even have a letterbox
they are not investors in  meaning of the
ect the yukos shares are also
not an investment and then I also come to
discuss the importance of the saline
criteria
the simple reasoning of the court has
been
HV have shares in yukos
oil company
shares are assets referred to in article
1 of the ict  and that is why avia is an
investor and and so that is that there
are those shares that are also an investment in
the sense of the ict and salini criteria
that do not apply according to the court of appeal because
they do not apply in ect cases according to the
court
that reasoning is incorrect  it is
widely accepted in arbitration practice
that the interpretation of the term
investment concerns the ordinary meaning
of
that term  as is also used in the standard
pronunciation
shalini morocco the
netherlands emphasized that during that bowl of
sprinkle I once again
emphasized and that cellini pronunciation is
very important I assume that you have
already studied it in the preparation for this session
because that and  if this is not the case, then you must do so
afterwards in that
decision, the arbitral tribunal has
ruled that there are a number of irons
to be regarded as an investment
it must concern a financial contribution
from the investor to a certain
activity that activity  must also have a
certain duration investor must
bear a certain risk and there
must be a contribution to the
economic development of the
host country and russia in this case that
between sliding of
hvna that angle as shares
domestic investment does not belong to their
investment in  the meaning of the
ect especially not now ave have paid nothing
they have not invested  on the
territory of russia and they did not
contribute to the economic
development of russia those cellini
criteria adopted by the
european commission in the proposals to
clarify the ect of the
concepts investor and investment
in the ict
the one hour and the one your  member states that
have rallied behind the proposals of
the european
commission and they are moreover
supported in this by other
ect states and during the judging
session they reaffirmed
and during that session the
commission noted that the
saline criteria that he  be the gold
standard for assessing whether
there is an investment
I arrive at an interim
conclusion opposite the view of the court of appeal and the
arbitral tribunal about the concepts of
investor and investment are therefore the
international used and see
the literature view of the committee
the view  from the in your member states and
from other etc states from that op  attting
of some more traffic I already mentioned the
rest of the world that also applies here
you can conclude
that domestic transactions that
acquisition by those dorothy olicharchen
that does not fall under the ict
that acquisition of by die rest oil
likes to fall of those shares so  also not
under the ect the sliding of
port in my does not make that any
different the cellini criteria that also
apply here have not been met and
what remains is keeping shares on paper
and that is not enough for
the  brand as an
investment
it about stan also wrongly
assume that hvna are investors and
that yukos shares used to be an
investment and that the selini
criteria would not apply to the ect
and insofar as you would already meet the
applicability of those shalini
criteria  If you have any doubts
, you should ask Luxembourg presidential questions on this point,
because it is after all up to the European court
to ensure  or a uniform interpretation
of the ict
that they mixed agreement in the european
union
now apart from that explanation of the concept of
investment investor is another
reason why hv he is not
entitled to protection under the ect and fundamental
principle of international law
obliges judges and arbitrator
namely to look through companies
that are used for abuse
for fraud or for other illegal
acts that has already been decided in the
barcelona collection judgment of the
international court of interest
court of justice
it has also been decided by isds directed
arbitrator who apply the same
principle  to
the extent that the Court of Appeal is now only
wrong to assume that this will not start in
ect cases, the general principle
of looking at companies that
are being used for abuse
applies, which also applies according to the European Court
of Justice in Luxembourg
in its rulings in  the these cases we
have put in the process  As
mentioned above,
the Court of Appeal ruled, citing
and repeating previous case law
that in the one hour there really is a general
principle that
litigants cannot
invoke
the current legal system and the associated
benefits in the form of fraud or abuse by means of fraud or abuse.  these cases
we have briefly presented it here
schematically it concerned these companies that
paid interest and dividend to their
parent companies in luxembourg and
sweden I say these cases were
two judgments and a total of six
judgments that have therefore been partly joined
together that Swedish  and luxembourgish
companies had little substance in their
home countries
just like av and he that
he had no success in cyprus and my
or denmark was now allowed to
withhold tax on that interest and that dividend
that i depended on whether those
swedish and luxembourgish companies
then wanted  a number of holders it is either
they or those shareholders
as ultimately  the rightful claimant could
be regarded as
an orphan
, the european court began to clearly
point out that many tax treaties
in the explanation of the model tax treaty already in 1977
are
based on that model
warn against abuse by
artificial legal constructions because
someone is a legal person  creates in a
certain state in order
to obtain treaty benefits that that
person cannot obtain himself a
legal person through which interest,
dividend or royalties only
flow, such as in the case of a conduit a
is a conduit company a butt
you the company
which, according to the oecd, is only an
intermediary no beneficial
owner and  it is therefore not
eligible for treaty benefits such a
conduit company may be the
formal owner,
but in practice it has only
very limited powers
we narrow paul calls it by how they do
it through which sea creatures only act as
administrator of the real
interest  nds who are of course
behind it again
acts according to the why
because of this constant exclusion of
through-flow companies
from 1977 ruled that a
through-flow company does not
enjoy protection of the one hour right and then
you have to have that, so we have that also shows that
picture there you have to  through look
no protection comes that transfer
company
av we enjoy there no
protection of the one you right in this
case the ect
av rice after all artificial legal
constructions that were created to really obtain the
protection of the one hour
that the russian oligarchs
do not  themselves
they have super in their locations they
have no office
no employees and no
business activities, in
other words they have no substance whatsoever
as it is called they do not have
is very narrow powers
they have no powers at all
they are even less than transfer
companies  and they are there for
[ __ ]  n companies without
independent meaning or powers
that have even been demonstrably used for
abuse
such as tax evasion and paying
bribes there is therefore no doubt that hv is
not entitled to protection under the
ect and if you would
like to doubt this
, you should ask  proposals to the court
of justice
for this have already been
made in the written explanation,
but they still boil down to the
following:
the russians cor and a few russians
who buy a
number of shares in a russian
company at an auction in russia
then slide  they company you that
among those that are less than through-flow
companies
you are not even letterbox
companies but that do have a sticker cyprus and
mine on them
and then the question arises
as a result of a cross-border
investment because now I think you can
answer that question yourself  answer that he
doesn't even give that to luxembourg  have to
ask
I get the reminder to
speed up something I will do that I come to
the 2nd avenue part 4to
the illegality and the violation of
public order and those are actually two
items illegally obtained goods that
cannot be regarded as an investment
and  protection of illegally
misappropriated goods is contrary to
public order
the russian oligarchs have obtained the yukos
shares through fraud and
corruption at a sham auction, which were
possible, among other things, by paying bribes
of at least 613 half a million
to the rest
i mean about four times
the amount paid by that also as a
share by the russian oil dig
led by the russian
oligarchs also evaded russian profits and sales tax on an
unprecedented scale
and those black profits have subsequently been
funneled away with the discovery of
dividend tax  and they are obviously
in the pockets of the russian  oligarch did
they disappear that corner was shares
themselves if the proceeds come out they are
therefore the fruits of fraud corruption
tax evasion in other illegal
acts according to the court that does not matter to
the jurisdiction of the arbitral tribunal
because the ict is not
explicit now time he  scant the court
says in effect that stolen goods must
be regarded as an investment protected by the ict
that oil is
incorrect
the initial investment in ect has an
inherent meaning and it is because that
concept does not include the proceeds of
illegal action
the explanation of the  of the court and now
sees whether there is a fairly lonely state in it is
also contrary to the purpose of the ect
which is after all so frank of the roelof
flow
with the case law of numerous
referees with literature with the
view of the european commission
the one member state  several other
ect stand in your country
ect countries and it is also contrary to
on because I of the arbitral tribunal  because
that judged that the investor's
bad faith is not protected by the
ect
pleading note the quote from
the arbitral award
stolen where there can be no investment
that therefore enjoys no protection under the
ict nor under any other treaty that are
not ice that lies in  the treaty
now decided that the court has
ruled that the
illegal trade in this case is
insufficiently evidently related to
the making of the investment by hve
that we say that the acquisition of duke or
shares for the court is only
important whether the acquisition of did you costs
shares by hv he that the strong
got those shares for free on that
sec was
illegal because
the court considers it irrelevant before and what happened to those shares afterwards
So the court actually
looked at that case through a lemonade straw
, it only looked at  the
to the acquisition through hatred he of the
yukos shares
not what happened outside that
lemonade straw vision is incorrect
the arbitral tribunal rightly ruled that
not only the last transaction
should be looked at but also the
previous transactions the divorce
right could not, however, wrongly not
determine how those shares obtained through fraud and
corruption
eventually ended up with the hvj
but that has now become clear through
the work of mr short arie
what he has recorded in undisputed
expert report
apart from this heel to acquire
the yukos share by hvj
correct in all respects context  with the
illegal act
yukos as juul was party to that
bribe agreement with the radar
rectus that created the appearance
that for the payment of those
bribes and legitimate cause
existed young also pay more than 600
million of those bribes and
thus the tourist
oligarchs could  you kos  t buy for a pittance
we have calculated it
comes down to about 3 percent of the
value they paid for
that bribe
that was a condition ustream see the qua
non for the later acquisition of those
also as shares by hv wf hv he
accepted therefore with that acquisition
shares that were illegal obtained
that they also knew what they
divide by the share of
accepting those shares is essentially healing
avia which also concealed the
undiminished control
because the top of that ratio body because
that was  the whole purpose of that shifting
they lock away the black profits and they
evaded hundreds of millions in
dividend tax
the conclusion is that they do play a central role in that corner
as shares themselves if the proceeds
from fraud through tax evasion and
other illegal acts
played a central role
obtained from an investment there is no
question of
hv we enjoy no protection
under the ICT and if  if you are still in doubt about this
, you should ask the Luxembourg court's opinion of the
second point of public order
protection of illegal goods is
contrary to public order
fraud corruption tax evasion and
other illegal acts are
against the public order of almost every person
country with a decent legal system
it is unacceptable that the hva and the
russian oligarchs would profit
from such an act as the court
and judiciary correctly
worded no one should profit from his own
wrongful act
the court's protection of the
proceeds of fraud and corruption is
contrary to public order and that
is not changed by the fact that those
proceeds are placed in it
seems on the shelves
that goods obtained through corruption
do not deserve protection also follows from
the treaty of peace nations against
corruption the secretariat of the
conference of state of that treaty
recently under v  reference to
report from 2009 10 confirm that
those who, like haven you, have a
connection with
beginning who commit a crime with us
do not qualify as third parties in good
faith and the secretariat also knew
that criminals set up precisely that
company or other legal
not to be used to hide their stolen
goods have that quote
also included
all those kinds of national and international
rules such as that corruption treaty against
against corruption against
tax evasion against money laundering and
against other abuse
all those rules become invalid as if
by stolen or by tax fraud and
other  goods obtained misuse
could be
placed with impunity in sham companies
intex sevens
and yet that is the consequence of the
judgment of the court of appeal
mr.
that's in st  time with the
public with national public order
european and international are made
public the
rest and the full arbitral award we
must therefore be quashed and
if you still have doubts about that
then you must ask luxembourg questions
i am giving the floor with your permission
anime
I will deal with the last part of the
next part 5 fatal omission of the
request for advice always
focus on the full
texts of the relevant provision in the pleading note
I am not going to propose it now, but I will
walk through with you  the sheets a
we the abbreviated version
whenever there is an issue that makes it
actions expropriation
tribe you know shell refer to the hood with
a lid for active in more wrong and I
pointed out that more wrong because in the first
sentence there is still a singular it  is also
another situation
the article 21 paragraph 7 gives the definition
for the ect of what then that jackson
farrar teach a and that are then the
bela  sting services of the involved
states
so from the what I always call your
name the guest aqua the investment has
happened and the establishment stares or the
home state of this
the via the investor and that
all goes back to a how-so model
treaty for
selling double  tax and it
states the rule that is expressly quoted in the
travaux préparatoires of the ect
that the intention is then that
the tax authorities of the two, in this
case, three state involved try
to arrive at an advice jointly,
I also pointed out, but the new thing is in the
plate notes not in what I am going to say now
the input of the swedish and the canadian
delegation for the blind and session of
tct happen on this provision and i
refer to articles by tasters a
park and
this national arbitrator mrs nepperd
who again say exactly this  that it
must be the
tax authorities and of both
the investor's home country and the
host state
therefore had the arbitral tribunal for the  ask
about the validity of the retrospective assessments and
that is the whole problem in the yukon
case first the advice you should seek
from those who texts for keith and
arbitral tribunal under the ect
power problematic issues about
tax and that is whether it is in our own
and the tax  is not to be treated
without such prior advice because the
first paragraph of article 21 states that
taxes are outside the treaty at all
,
but if it is an expropriation
tax then it can be
suggested
nevertheless we request this ship's rights despite
6 russian formally laid down
already from this  in the first years of
the arbitration 2005
consistently to ask for those opinions and
the only ground on which that happened that
read again nine years later in the
final judgment of all the word
it would be an exercise in futility
a name that comes from ave from the
procedural
documents and  the court therefore
stated in so many words that refusing that
request for advice
should not mean that it  an order was
violation in the sense of 1065
and that there is no futility ekseption
make sure that maybe in the ect there is
so an order does not seem more
than the court will be fine partly a 'half to 3
apologies you are final judgment why it
anyway  the first excuse
is
that skipping the russian
tax authorities would not be a serious enough
violation of the order and why
not
because russia as a defendant in the
arbitration could have said everything its
tax authorities would have said if it
had been asked for advice and  that is why
the court spontaneously concludes that there was no
disadvantage to that disadvantage
I will come back to you separately, but that
ground for refusal is
insufficiently serious here in any case
wrong by law
the ect is obligatory after all, everything is
focused
on complicated tax ask for
advice from those two or three
tax authorities involved  to ask
and now the simple answer is that that
guy aad
who is by definition the defendant in
an ect  arbitration overload by that
guest nature and what the court does in
fact do is delete the mandatory
treaty provision that the advice about it
must be requested
because then say not necessary
because the minister or the lawyer of the
state
k say exactly the same as that
tax authorities
the second  excuse that concerned has come up
with is that ect no advice spirit of
the tax authorities run cyprus and poor
and cruel kingdom so that excuse
is also wrong in law
the reasoning given by the court there is
that the hvj did not say in their arbitration
yes also cyprus and isle  or they have
imposed our own in taxes
it is not the criterion at all
but first of all we ill on the
procedural error still by russia of
course
and this ref has still been argued by the hvj
that only then an advice
from cyprus and isle or one had asked
may be or should be as
you purportedly imposed against the
taxes
so this is an unauthorized  rrassings
decision of the Court of Appeal in violation of
Articles 19 and 24 of the
legal action and from the quotes
with which this chapter began
it appears that the excuse is also
materially incorrect,
always in this type of tax dispute
the advice of
and from the tax authorities of the
further  the guest nature and the establishment
state
and now the third excuse of the court
the advice omission did not cause any
disadvantage
also that virtue really not something
I read about us that your
process is very
important that this is not a disadvantage
argument does not occur with  the refusal
of the request
for advice to cyprus and a peaceful kingdom that
is simply because it is not
suspicious that what I just said is
nonsense but that also means that that
failure not to ask the advice
of those two other tax authorities
yates independently the destruction  of
the court address and thus of the
arbitral tribunal
according to justifies
well in itself apart from  deep very
important internet
indeed justifies under dutch
law only the sufficiently serious
violation of the orders destruction
but this is a very serious
violation
and, moreover, this is detrimental to the ear and
a person
however it is very serious to the this
also highly dead  chair mental vol
russia de deliberate violation of a bit
of a [ __ ] i like you know of already months
tree article widget specifically for
tribunals aas en output because je 565 bn
eye
ict by itself is already sufficiently
serve to justify setting is
of trol die op location  for referral
it has been choose object of ict
négociations decisions about normal
lyrics speeds
full outside the powerfly pianos and most
arbitrators 500 it for the atmosphere and
for a tag slow what the second reason
why when no ham or someone or the code
fell was fierce  that's quite a
profile already so I
[Laughter]
in need no no
o no o no no
that factual background we have to
ee  ns step back in time
at the beginning of the 90s the
soviet union fell apart 14 states mainly in the more
densely populated areas
split off as you can see here on the
slide
the remaining russian federation
saw martin the following years a deep
political financial and economic
crisis through and see the data that way appear on
the screen that are
illustrative imf data and see
that especially at the beginning of the 90s
the crisis was huge the russian
gross domestic product fall of over
1000 billion dollars there so'  $ 90
billion and even at the end of the 90s this
was not back to the old level
then president Yeltsin wanted to implement
rigorous economic
reforms but this was hindered
by the existing constitution that was
outdated and under that power lay to a
large extent with the russian
parliament  and this led to a house shifted a
power struggle between yeltsin and
parliament can you imagine that now
remember that our world news this
battle was settled with the constitution of
1993, which came about after a
positive
referendum and in that new
constitution the power of the russian president
and his government was greatly expanded
and that was of course at the expense of the
power of the parliament  and one of the
areas in which that president was given a lot of
power and that's why i mention this
was foreign policy and the
power to make treaties the
president sets
foreign policy guidelines
he negotiates and signs international treaties
the government for foreign countries stays
out  and can I also negotiate that connection
or international
treaties and sign these
albeit always under the supervision and
responsibility of he is there again
the president to
negotiate treaties and sign the first one
also has the power to pass the
provisional application of a
treaty and  that is even possible
if that provisional application
would conflict with existing
russian legislation it is important
that we use our energy you that this
is arranged differently in russia than in
many western parliamentary democracy
you like about the netherlands
[music]
from 1992 the president started to see money
and his government with a large-scale
privatization jumped the three phases
the aim of that was three line
first the companies from the soviet era
had to be brought
back to work and they had to
be made fit to operate in a
market economy our came to
communist system
at  secondly, the
debts of those companies must be prevented
from increasing even further, those debts included
enormous arrears of tax
obligations and unpaid wages of
employees and thirdly, the
entire state treasury had to be filled urgently
another instrument that he wanted to be
one by one  use to get the
russian economy out of the sl  to
draw up was the conclusion of investment
treaties,
this also included the ect
this became mother federation refueled at
17 december 1994 in russia was also one
of the driving forces behind the ict
the russian energy sector had
the potential to bring
the country out of the doldrums economically
attracting, but the lack of
investment prevented this from being
realized in order to make that investment as
attractive as possible,
the ect offered the widest possible protection
to investors and their
investments
as defined in article 1
paragraph 6 and 7 of the ect
no additional requirements were therefore
imposed on the concepts of investor in
investment, for example proposals to add
the requirements of control or substantial
business activities were
rejected we are the things that there is
federation tries to read in again
further investors with  ray
for damages if their
investment were to be expropriated  nd
under article 13 of ect but also boot
de it is up to investors to enforce the
necessary basic
legal protection through
international arbitration
that you will find in article 26 ect ect was
mainly intended to stimulate investment in
former eastern bloc countries
but nobody would
want to invest substantially there
without international arbitration
protection
the problem was the instability and
above all the lack of independent
institutions including an experienced
functioning
and independent judiciary
it also
injustice the lack of an
independent national judge the
power leads us that we see daily in the
news and happy and we praise  we are
happy that there is no such thing in the Netherlands
,
we have the floor space regulation of article 26,
so it was a core provision of the ect because of
the need to attract investments as quickly as possible
, the
russian federation made during the
negotiations and when
the ect was signed  insisted on provisional
applications of that other had
to come into effect as soon as possible
she has thereby ripped number of any
violation of her law and also
afterwards and stated repeatedly and
publicly that the
provisional application of the ect
did not conflict with her national
law that was  also logical in view of the
very broad powers
accorded to the presidents by the constitution to the presidents
his government to get over the provisional application
of treaties
master ching sandra
come back to this in more detail than I come to
whoppers
the privatization of oil and
gas companies whoppers largely took
place 1995  and 1996,
just as it was during that time, there
was
no opposition at the same time among many other large state-owned enterprises
, led by the head
of the communist party, who had a
chic or not untouched attitude, there is
no misunderstanding that after
that moment
already unexpected  election victory in
the presidential elections of 690
that
would be ready to nationalize the privatized state companies
that made investing in privatized
companies such as whoppers
risky and that god all because the
communist party won the
parliamentary elections in 1995 it was
at this juncture
that the new shareholders led
public also order coffee  and his
business partners by the bus federation
invariably pejoratively referred to as
oligarchs
that they acquired their interest in whoppers
that happened through auctions
set up
by the Russian federation and conducted by it
that also happened on the basis of
valuations and minimum prices determined
by the Russian authorities  the federation criticized the
privatization freilingen now 25 years
later alleged irregularities
when, however, the russian judge
ruled in three instances already in 1996
that this auction had been lawfully
conducted in that procedure, the
russian judge  federation nota bene
also defends that privatization is
lawful places around
also the russian federation during the
high book of this destruction
procedure suddenly
start to see privatization and bribery at that premium
when studying the documents
this essentially argues for nothing more than a
stick on  are small
to keep certain yukos managers involved in the
company they knew
about the spanner in the works when it came to
oil and gas production by joep as
something the new to the veins
had no mega knowledge or more
experience more the
there is russia  and also never
prosecuted anyone for what is now called a
bribery and that is so remarkable
because we the show federation has possessed the
documents they suddenly claim
as here for a long time and the
russian authorities are obliged to
prosecute little reasonable
suspicion of criminal  facts but such
a reasonable suspicion is
apparently not
the company at the time
Despite its potential, the privatization was in a billable
state as it was established by the russian government in April 1993
as a
capital company
in which several separate production and
distribution facilities were
merged
, however, it had not yet been legally or
factually reorganized
the company was also weighed down by
sequins russian federation users  wins
2nd point about restoration
there was an osn easy puff the wind reed or
rattan
the techni show in the google glasses and
you can see
lord i had it the udder dive
immediately got my heart ehm ftth
out of your coffee vartan business or the
ever  a good effect of google glasses
all the russian jb current marshall
ready was lazy and eat the small near her
to that the net to graz
now
oil with my sisters 5
discussions in the min stand other lego
cia carcass times adhd production of
silent  she is true but after some swiss
sense for business mostly and herr
wesley model and tips about transparan  tie
and accounting exactly to a
competition in the company
lucas and shorty kept coming in is
production and distribution and quietly
so so it's simple you
barely integrate the eating strings
nothing is done about the scarf sets are since
plexi to the family and  sets and the oil
and gas puddles switch of the media and
neptune accessories globally father or
mother to the sales and at the end of
2002 you closer door to commit the
drawers already quite a producer and pleasure
where you are and leather herba tt-01
dallas
lord in 2000 hours the metric part one
billion in prophecy and making your
house add and leave yuan per dollar and
start the youth house knightley and dear
ferry bmw 2002 and revolution we want
it in the valley of the process or the
professor who  well see that the much your
the client fast
and the rupel course is that i have you a
serious him in oil of 2000 ambitious
every course new commission anyway
you off kta2 that woman stock options
that it's your website and your edge
when something about age iii white
terry cooper eighties and nineties
even preferably foil and jill and in 2000 and
one and that's fat charm that usb2 nike
nike nike 2000
one e2 white quaternary shares and you
and the  tribe jonas wie het cot
and most stable radian die ingram there
arises holly and johan required on the
grateful dead us love patrick which is
actually pension fund for a preview
cost had a quarter inshared formula
lovely age you buy or normal
lodge with holding company is what er  one
assets other not the pen death and
we-feeling
work attitude activity in accordance
with the applicable legislation and
regulations
well the tribune already or so often truly a
city is dependent on the code files and
the battery is just a little bit dead
when look at it  is not sufficiently
connected to my clothes you and i put
it your spoonful of cognac that reportedly piece of
meat and ninety nine to five a bit
neat x there is dioxin
incidentally the code  for piel he so
sick holy [ __ ] so ledett
elastic as never as efficient often
julienne twitch there were no sense or
understatement
well weapons from the top
review oil 2002 was demons the most
efficient at camp is in the basement in that
your contacts explore traditions or a
wedge reduction the balance and look around
and i see your code cost goals i became
increasingly active in the social and
political scientist rinus and you with an
astronaut peck the federation däniken
nation angie als lex feast corruption in
the russian government and so it was very
great
a short  koski even helps puts into
account for the corruption live on
television and this is part of the speech
he keeps the time and
and in which i put that corruption and
in russia there followed runs on first
billion dollars and white score koski the
game prominent political opponents
president putin
putin the grizzly so politics alone
follow me duke osteoporosis became in fact
and regime family inter friend
dramati  cally in 2000 and free
before the coffee there was adventure
leo frying trials that for a that the
limit e19 chemical products que le
point i would be detained in siberia
until the end of 2013 with the sametime and
centrally also the residential fine
compound set in  motion to destroy index
propria cures and government
institutions ran the active eat you this
account is individual gunk for
video chats with juns favorite mineez
charm prisons and put under severe
pressure to make follows statements and god
turn i will paul is general opportunities
for you chose mr alex  and jan is as if
harvard and lammles
now there is remains that him if one is in hold
my review motion plus a new
is minecraft
sympathetic and beaches no typhi
infection and subsequently here was of
the freedom and medical treatment in
exchange for making in criminals in
tests  with this chance miss code koski
and miss shirley company and there is a
video
do you want them here because screen clac in
statements t  o the russian supreme court
in an appeal by alexia from
tells how i was offered liberty full full
statements a new views die set
iphone nozbe full switches die need
beat the innocent people though hubo the
consequences is the speakeasy we script
in pre-trial de  sides v2 is pending
blasted and this was on the
circumstances whitewashed federations
also you might skansen modestus quite
simply man stress
the volume rami girls in which post by
the european court of human rights to
hang alexanne it with you two
specialized hospital eindhoven
independent commission touches  condition
de maidens dat het bimhuis with
improved by
the russian federation and in the end
was that moment
big on impulse a huge soon
assessments on us at all in a very fast
pace you need ultimate  ly mount wit you
twenty-four
trillion dead to be paid and just a few
days and at the same time it was this
blog deprived of a fair trial at which
to challenge the
stocks assessments  sabse van die de
rational kind is designed to work in a
few cost touch-ups it's extremely
prices and a 10 ex other typical fries
apple
something methods were transfer
foil prejudice to skate oil company rosneft
which can shop tab in
vali pike's it's a this process  the
shareholders' equity of rosneft in 2002
2006 and in 2004
hundreds of my assets of yukos
take your costs useful as was transfer to
rosneft
to be followed by some other assets to
the valeo of bosch neff recording the
group in the period 2004 2006 python's x
100 percent
well this expropriation of yukos was a
turning point shots is the lead
expropriation in history km
tea products que le point and strength
and define and soul power bass de
russian regim  e this is an ex life which
who still needs monti
picture you show you [ __ ] usa
time with the put into question at adhd
annual press conference absolutely show
became the dolls badri between the
business community and the buddies public
powell is clearly defined sets putin en
eeuwse  set of german disagree with a
college
pacino we need life and what the roelof was
lost the medical soil is chip
haha in death the finish line in this conte
t the april lead rod o
er percentages indep
nder got in a flow even
hat power now to six pack to the russi
n  federation as in the case that
this will never voluntarily php die
the dams and hey you see the on
for the official spokesperson of the
russia ministry of foreign affairs to
question
bodyguard to hack with this code file
this case is a cheatday smith who is the
ministry  of justice in the netherlands a
split climate possibly in violation of
legal proceedings something like where i doubt
full of water drastically we lief active  ly hz
scholes
de russian federation screw is
minister of justice and you see him i
share this with love december even
pointed out that through the preceding
see this fight in a legal bocouture
a coach in which the russian
federation
mastiff and this self earth quickly and
some  plants even just tackled is frans
anders an explicit reference to this
people the idea even
it is doing everything for example and
its power to present age your iphone
inside whatever their fools who also want
roots and very recently the russian
federation
oh man this is constitution and  after his
effendis legal mud pits in order
theological constitutional culture and
the judgments behind closed doors and a
floating recovery lm briefly and outside
the sphere
activations you hear and can say a few
words which the russian federation fine
to distract it and of with a couple
contact and  offset of the prime resources
loic without exception of your services
position defended by the russian
federati  on and dia locations arnold
oil wells davy levels a review
cheetos false accusations aligns with
evidence in many home page the exactly
how document in defining instances that
those sonications wholesale anti-military
elephant the russian federation
waved checklists dancing advice
relevant activations
and white black template you
toddler festival most the russian
federation presented its role and clean
go bag sessions as a setting
aside from out of time as i this
is already in the region aging white
science for this reason they must be
disregarded
and in addition the code much decided at
the  alleged idealistic on or drive and
study assessment of the jurisdiction
other article one shots x and c mini city
my mind and i find will explain this
recently i chose to the point je dan met
de drive unit ali recognize another
complaint by the russian federation
aan  i this is at sonntags in the gel it
's the biasi minisite in the dreef
contribute c  hain necklace and send as a
result apply discounter no
less than sexy pin 7 trillion in the
confiscation of damages which you might
not agree with bad are you vs in the
fabien as decision as already said russian
federation shoot
the russian federation if they did this  still
dispute that is an argument has been
accepted in this way and it means that i
saw the devil may be disposed of
in the effect context leslie the russian
federation is trine 2 us activations
classic lyme and with the cart and try
discussions on a veces with  ambitious
intex avoidance and in this way
with rapture active effects the stranger
tides the ict
that is not possible because négociation
of the killer bless the ict
on your site ribbon and this moment that treaty
and of course there can be no and tcpc and
respect event less  treaty of
location set hf be agreed that
actually
and so arvid finds a conclusion the
context and the history of this cache also
that if there are results of the economy
p  roblemen in de night with russia has
made a great effort you make states and
companies competitive edge activism in
economics en wit that last objectif in
mind brochures and medical portrays the
ict and its in media professional
application in modern design de
bronen repeatedly dat de bridges  of the
ict we consistent with is loon this so
far that professor application in any way
however one investor's of three bushel
expropriation inspired by political in
financial beings
guido what adam ii society of assisi
albert becomes for bional dates and like
en lief in the wind
the russian federation apples elstar jets
lingmont
mike is the floor to my colleague mr
cheng
but that in this part of the war
clothes [ __ ] myths chance the hive
appeals there is no better god sent tribunals
tourist and the great vpro thank you
so the photo it now  viewer and ethiopia
or i later my two that subject and
that is sympathetic le pike east the
russian federation
a great ma  ny many every man and on or
box all comments
we skin looked at if you them at the
tribune and reject in 2d
oil the my princess hd 2tb can be
discussed
the russian federation is required to
provisionally reply article 20c team
idea
alteration close and age 1  ice tea spot
that is demonstrate pale and arguments
mailbox land lactose of dermolin spin
explicitly and repeatedly kon van die de
russian federation from the outset that
i must professional guy de ict
it was coach with i bought this page
you why the russian federation he
started to  in fethiye latch die az
witches of carl dix angles
intellectual flexibility to which a
white lies from the code for piel it
reviews degree dance now based on an
chekov photos 5 apply his
obligation to prevent learn ply de ict
and you see homeless heron so like this
is the english text sayin to the extent
that such professional application is
not inconsistent with a national oh oh
the signatory in question
the russian  federation green de
negotiations and at the signing of the
ict will is a system to de
professional aplication der wolf
welnee van mentioning any and
consistency of its national laws and you
see a number of slides in which the
various moments all pictures het goed de
russian federation
thats about this particular is now being
the negotiations and mine tonight it's
been a key for free sample de russian
federation of both
de de lee no over de ben draft article
om professional application and add new
boyz jerry discussions de russian
federation point out and inconsistency
with  regard to twenty six ict
al detail arbitration kinky
article is considered a very significant
i dit menschen by the way that 5 of ict
provisions for all ages link and 16 bit
neuro en het stip widget and exception
photos but this neville engine article
20c
ict in dat  list subsequently the russian
federation sign the ict
met oud choosing to deliver an applause
declaration which is somethi  ng the
treaty provide enough you make such
declaration
and signatory is not obliged to
enforce for 15
what rocks conventions easy cheese cake
and something incidentally if you sammy the
russian federation repeatedly yes man and
beekjes seemed to him that this was prefer
sleepline the ict in its entirety and that
the provisions a clothing
item twentysix ict table already in conformity
with russian [ __ ] there al die  xplory notes
for i shampoo of the comments to the
proposal to ratify the city's the [ __ ]
is t them and access and excel public you
can see you could the screen and
in this was a fact that the provisions
working system with russian legislation
and they do not  require the adoption of
any
a moment
professional
nou even in 2000 for the russian
federation handsome sam study ict
secretariat other the slope times
art  iesten foreign investors
that de investment' de striker krolse
bi-sexual stream international
arbitration and the great and i
despise foruminvest shall be settled according
to the international agreements and
feather release of the russian
federation
in court of arbitration orie lee
international court of arbitration and
2000  and according to mr before the
arbitration ska least in 2605 us now
polly's conformation sinnfoort have
ample pattern bits provincial
application has long been bowl and tricks
in the russian federation
at the time the ict assigned de was a
federation was profile earplug no fewer
than for each  piece and won i will call
of such a family pride fiji is the
salvage seek and then check which the
limits de my timebaan 3
dietwin the soviet union no terrace on
the united states and this convention
requires ratification before is prominent
en trientje vol speakers de  laminating
it is basic effects
fed legislation nevertheless this
convention  n has been brazil prive
even such as snow and on the slide you
see your tweezers from the website of the
russian ministry of foreign affairs and
in the stated of it that the belgian
conventional science few nike nike and
ready since 15th june nike nike has the
treaty  been previously
night and this profile i like to this
key this is as extra or critical that there is
great interest second such as
such as with zipper mede pandiyan accession
of vanilla in march 2014 en i you see
the signing of this on the special
significance this  treaty is clear of
the ceremony on sign in
by president peter
out in myth die absolute was site it be
gone to be professional i apply despite
a fight but they change the bulldozer the
russian federation and even a national
achieve the inhabitants of the primary
these borders  niobe is you so that we left
to the primary legislature
a king second russian
constitutional pencil and resolution
shakespeare the many applications de
taymiyyah and acc  ess and treat a treaty
is never inconsistent with the separation
of poles
well the wasjes federation kids completly
silent i bought a treaty and the
interpretation and possibly bytes and
note candy jar and the house week
oil silent of the subjects check liter
in that war jenson april here  in de
henk en leed september 2010 part two
weeks before deeds hering it means
before
the strasbourg cools and unclear in
the russian federation convention that this
forest
profiline came through an eccentric i
basically into every site and rolled
ground for cas échéant north formula
lights red  you simplify nice place der
about the unmistakable significant de
code subtle touch die professional
education and i chose according to
support en die [ __ ] dat de separation
of powers of the consequences te russian
federation the touchpad you now only
once e2 white was in follow this de russian
federation in arbitration said the
prism application of art corinthian
ict was inconsistent  t met is national of
eden led set was allegedly
can be used for the separation of paulus for
the russian federation to be bound by
professional education with an agency
of parliament moral al irrational
de the muscle 2d dual is a ledett lino
turbo and the switch  a german the russian
federation
why not require two professional and
play all the cosmetic ict the champion
all right way dismiss
this argument to the code video game to
this its conclusion
the code for pylons rejected the russian
argument to put two in the pan and wreath and
the  supreme court conventus in the
suspension decision
specific members chorophyll vials s2 the
provision operation of article twentysix
ict is contrario in conflict am
rational and consistent with rational
at sunrise interpretation with an
imitation and close switch the chorophyll
accepted is correct and and seek grapes
lewis learn sex  with the article 236
ict this is itself consistent with fashion
european of the interprétation gi  ven to
the limitation close by this is coated
to the fresh federation on this means a
limburgse due to the hive appeal decided
there was now in the consistency there is now in
consistency wit word template this
most russian federation bunch stuart
god want isings ethics would serve  and
the protection of the limitation close
from the fust independent newspaper of the
coach for pawn in saves the limitation
close must be a chopper chats
jimmy at the signatory disliken russian
federation is never measure on card
application is a blige to apply the
treaty provision this is  jeff er oil of
provision application is inconsistent with
national oh and consistently with
national sp shimmy signs that the
looze regulations it at always motionless
professional application of a great way
for specific types each other there are two
the provisions and sit the mcz is interpretation
special question  whether
national a choice is the professional
applications at insites each other sprays
two that prov  isions
and this is our color of the text namely
the words such professional application
the russian federation and cross-section
complete in my that the test is never
water the exact application is can
inconsistent with checked grammy ict
provision myself is inconsistent with
national ditch
professor folders  a sheet wind direction
so complete
i go to the code papyrus decided to
twenty six siege or so in the
interpretation or the federation is never
inconsistent with russian [ __ ] and this
decision was a [ __ ] canopy test is for
something is correct in cassation and
compliance in respect  of the reason and
directed against it already many dear
picasa komplein zo'n anysurfer a [ __ ]
but even de korven piels interprétation
is correct
de language of the limitation close
unmistakably indicates that the issues
with such professional application is
inconsistent white larvae contact info i
have in  deportation of the russian
federation
there is now measurements touch so what are  de
korf appeal rightly notarial actions the
breadths do you know the orly meaning of the
line budgets provisions in is in the
professionals the ict is in the
professionals and had to be in the code with
the context and that object and dads that
position and this is our compound
by de trafo nou p stone age
interpretation of the limit show is the
positive pielen subsequently your stable
is that if you need north contain any
rules excluding the provision application
of article in the city
russian lo the president and the cover man
half or roll bread  piece a club critically
in clothing the poles
232 the professional application of a
treaty the power is necessary jack the
restrictions
in dus and start in russia aprilia blythe
critias de cm effect from a voucher
for treaty on those who takes fressen
dann slide
formal national legislation even  nefit
is inconsistent tweezer switches that
basilica friend and evans impact
the was a president and gave him a box
and make free to use of  de power to enter
into the treaties wit professional
education
in fact and education ik Simpel en adsl
sweex preseli in situations in which
they have to respond to from the
political and economic s was info
de case ict and this practice with laid
down by de constitutioneel
Groot  was his fans explicitly the proud
teacher north wind
paulus is laid down in the constitution
nike nike free and is also a parent of
brush and treaty practical and the leds
bit offset tricks and too much in the
breaks to brush a pointer
departure win the doctor the fed  om
international treaties
flash in shot and the flash contains
intermediate fishing without professional
application of treaties and juicy
article 20 friese one flash here to the
screen and inline at dark funky five
devinnent conventional critical this
provision provides for its entry into
force e treaty may be supplied
provisionally body wash and
federation of the paint and treaties and
provides of contract in parties have
agreed a few tips which the case in
this might san marco 20 free software
fibers and reveal any limitation s2 the
treaty provisions of tried to cut crisis
situations and can be applied
professionally
iraqis and in
resolution
epi of 2012
the shocking independence approaching
grande of the code feel for its decision
is based on the interprétation dave a
second limited edition' close fact
districo tender russian federation and
sidebar gadget per december during in
the question of whether and provision
ikzelf  cd arbitration close this itself is
inconsistent with national aid to in
morocco of four seven the final judgment
substantiated with hyde extensive
freezings om 20 for hats for drawbar
and the hives pi same as i
decided and article 20 sexycity is needed
consist and this self with russian  loren
that the series is correct
from the porridge of the five that is actress
channel b16  causation
this challenge en sap grande rue
princesse portland street triple six
pound 5 in vienna white complete in respect
or freezing third compliance manager for
0 this thinline with what the brains and
griffiths like is wasted licet is
see more and elizabeth was now logic
damien this the  russian federation
this site with touch t10 wheel tweezers
picos epfl detail beaufort's obligation
to apply the city provisional
duck baskets pinus presidium seth dolder
safe in the accu mens and rejected him
in a good choice foto groove garden en
so is in foil en but i would be good
to bring pizza leeuwarden chorophyl
decided the friendly of the district
court
the russian federation is karma
patriarchy mens is 2 article 20c
psychotic registry intentions and
operational dc who already the principal
and separation of powers
said this the others russian
loden the spido davy was quite big trouble  and in
cedar underbrush keep a box so if
they are positive nor entitled to file a
k  lein forever [ __ ] damage van de korfen
piel we get it that last argument for
the sorry that this model has nothing
to do
with the question of whether artikel 2 die
sessions 3gb applied
that guy is so small grace voor de
river damage but if this will
definitely how you can ot house at your
little anne the ict nutrition consistent
with rational
well with regard to all key with eggs
line of the separation of powers the code
[ __ ] you first sight it is that on
wood begins based on the point of
departure it  article 20c seti is a
form of dispute resolution that there
again from the fed resolve the russian
federation
pico stad is the key of this argument of
fdc pike's it is the european economy
show without van center parliament that
is a correct point of departure
encore appeal  refers to death to which
rejection of the argument that the
disc tray we die two why would not
supposed to be
albert rational medicine
grumble read what the code f  or
people house of extensive louis sans
die brief reboot other russian punching
journal of the government just about
every day the treaty will be a pride
provisionally even of the critically
inconsistent with fed us aan den Koning
tot de co2 wie je boring bad separation
of powers
this  channel b successfully al cute that the
government has six siege is among the
three in professional education
well our die argument that the dispute
with free wi-fi never albert rabo liner
brush and lobi critical positive
public lo disc u dat channel be settled
sleep crash  and we like me just nothing
on my teeth
widek van de korfen piel the code for
pewdiepie de dat de l'eau son foreign
investment the nike nike one mit
ninety-nine
en nevel international investments
arbitration
to the bases of the treaty and in some
money  words and you see his words the
provision om de screening the dispute
about foreign investors raise in
connection with investments shabir
isoufi in de men prescribed  by
international treaties of the russian
federation
afm motionless in a cotillo arbitrage
coat of international arbitration
course breathless and the trick that
practical russian federation also shows
in it resp in the shed national
old school go numbers those two
that super vibe that corbion
transfigures people repair
federation  this form of dispute
resolution
he is even experts walked in sign is the
political party in far
restrictions will be the two the practice of
the russian federation
that naturally for sale be a
new one for the strongest
international krishna then dispute all
in respect quarrels and  breadwinner dc
supplying
the goose dad and the russian federation
confetti operations and fancy piet it
seemed from the ict is that i the system
it was a wage the characteristics of the
stated in the astonishing out weir type
processor of the ict and you can see is
again  on the screen
where does it open easy jihad assistant
knows I was 16 and  through his life experience
and swim new from
nature there is my home and here you
see the empty regime of fine investments
a face on the ict is
consistently the provisions of the xx
is theologian in accordance with s.th
as well as with him and fresh  overflow
concrete being discussed in the stitch
dumas en and zo is in my team edge
5 and who m in this fashion side you
discussed in the stitch number is what
automatic price about as pc gaming 10
and 10 to respect so that session base is
international  that the districo confused
factory party in the press controlled and
is in the big peel swung in
life in the in respect and the supreme
court table
so not wanted guys crash what the
matter temptation is absolutely i suppose
to remedy can in temptation is the u
will roman cm i see the answer
session he himself is never a [ __ ] sister
must red bull and recording medication or
tassel hotel t good who has something
real work or become often that is
event to th  e combing before rush
hour slipping dedication to ask question to
the court of justice
this ten brink's may to grab fixation
tree with can be since have lyrics
was constant sixandseven on the edition and
the short period what you the boring that's
who why can be qualified  as a western
must and investment' jasmine tea to
definition chose hadi you see here to the
screen and the waves po
he replaces fact became xvi where a
company stands if the the risks also an
iced in the fever want we won spot in
deed can assets'  see that there are still
and that those six success
psv white and ready for this reason and
she was a
investors white and investments actually
worth by the city
after the chose to live and or just sex and 7
the emergency set further they came to the shape
character  in west of the western lesson
point articles 0 exceptions be made for
companies and workshops about the fitness
time had interest
now there is in my pie sufficient
business activities on developing
coun  try of which have national c en
need article won she
six is it iso values that wester but make and ec
nomic contribution home countr
and russian federation complaint a
d cassation a doubt the interpretat
on that the short for pls kill and the two
die separations critical an
attendants  dm no more
we have time with 0 comments
and we god is wreak specially
have on in satisfied
the core cpu wesley hardin authors
fiction
nou t van lodges budget in the fast red
lotus lychee red
petticoat driver wash dishes that i have
space the quests workers  address in
europe man set often so there are
two greetings bo3 statements
evolution federation
[Music]
extensive teaching was this they the russians
further is a task moment so still in
the spot in the texts the ict parasols
sewer is in the is national
that text is religion that reflects to
ncsoft patisse
it is the ceiling the moss our concerns
define tennis
the coast the find them softly eagle and
the  ed when time is I realize that I am
leading to the chance of the regime and
in accordance with a passion for what a
very warm about the financial of crazy
that specific and opinion but mirror
a period I will also push
major recruiting and sixth basket  as a
found
that the jarvis of the city and i consider
the grudge area that was a federation
start your app becomes interdisciplinary
to the time the oceans to the ict
impetigo is concert out and soon
the ie on the western dependent already the
nationality or  those who control
interest in the west and or so en
requirement as efficient
social business inkjet was concert
cities then is processed and
consistently reject it
and fifth of the definitions there are
well in color does in ict and it
starts cakes
not possible to get  in trevor
home is common in trip name and rocks the
context that is the position of the schools
often der lion further also weapons can be
worried got so off claude objec  t
empathetic vcp
budget afro is really [ __ ] investments
as much as possible and white definition
of in west and investment' is where the
features laugh so this
specific sp way next to my suitcase pio
and this season is when they foil
headline china and risk  bureau
water preview on these issues de russian
federation affairs at to the decisions
on growth in the food have this advice
is recognize teachers idea that there is
still event and at a treaty and use it to
nsfw says that thing about the
interpretation of ict en  see there is a
coarse profile is our white line so we
go someday national courts in the catrice
awareness the fans corazon i spoke
sleeuwen jack time and was in the easy
typical investment and advertising to
migraine dues is two and temper
is and so with ferro spray  bread our
experts lie then forms the critters or
article because 7 is something
the national team of the veste is a
lead time in two hits tough
kutcher vote shanti  in west myself
the national the legal entities and
exercise control over six wind is north
recruiting in my conversation
decor voc we jack we saw that the is the
news firstly gets wet weather spot but
because the magic it's the girl where
qualifier stacks measures next to god  wants
someone does he look like that [ __ ]
alternating trichet
ground right will have a break obligations
with respect to x beige so is that so
big cava well in that the need or
ipl this provision death note effects
joysticks of the uitburo
because this first section is is  between
having
the past truth the provisions of article 20
sex is the salvation there is now a the pen
it seemed s'posing substantial china or
that i hear vs decision he medical per
bottle empty the coffee pods she did that co2
dewanee city oli policy send
inland shipping  text girls and there was
that there is juliet o s2 desk of and
adjoined a tissue that the chabrillane
who could have your own decision and its
wings days people and we s  defy image
sports lotion pies videos from the soul
is incorrect
and the nasty discussions the cups this
a geesjen
sugar is time for step list and see i see
it is them with her the text girls so
to the bases verdict decisions that cor
vpl and where they define  conclusion that those
two bureau in the jurisdiction
he ordered cover to the conclusion s
i want my fly notes
electric cigarette to article 20 one
easy a few words and this is in line
with mates his beard in various
foundation
precision so that you can test this is  is now
the waves period was food that kun cm
ground clearance and sex girls
the issue of the issue where
that the russian federation is racing yes
how explain 5
their content you see do you miss the father
you naughty my rebate
even question arises be tex measure
is and expression and expression of the
leisure in the addresses and it is provide
white jersey ionary solid mass to the
lid in vain recent
and that we vision is polluted you is  the
clock the clock and such sometimes and i sexy granny
proficiency
that's oil and section which is lady cop
out of what at kuoni
was exactly on sexual revolution and
that god in t els but the treaty if your
self is not about sex girls am
other than the plate or you can be
narrow fire trucks girls and why
lovejoy eartips a tourist out in
section view of a gradual a condition
scratches pielen cassation how i live
who sticks at tp vision their many
applications is still clickable him because
the text girls  in postman russian
federation of yukos we wet bonfire the
ears were so in such event
the cover out or so sister was up
to your ali is that they place and that's the
exception to that exception decided plate
the cloaca 5 is deception of course a
mistake over formed  and consciously off
february city and she likes that is a
spots ball charlie was like hero
when we catch so purely on the trucks
girls i angry terrace in mind
to action quotes
and all would often off forma  ggi
kabila act of use a bridge is a
general chat the game and duty practice
this also means there was no love and
oppression and have to a grand
casablanca party for is simba has
perception route baskets piolet this
application
diks ist wenn die short we po  while i
decided to stand on
tackling that the velia tulle is not
sufficiently serious to justify the
settings we will speak together and
miss eyre
just said there further budweiser
shaking show lips through the case british
positive and marssum
the christian tissue is here  whether i'd
prefer oh kut have resulted in suntek
infant and the coral bay of actually
by
failing to refer to the extra virgin
scott the toad said the copies of
sufficient there was a federation of 6
bar het radio and the information that
direction fed  eration that was very chic
rubber garden-party of
tenders it wishes at the russian federation
oil stab and abc white russian
federation
[ __ ] north cultivation silence takes to
itself absolutely there is a taxi for it is
this temple on i you exactly so there
for who is there  in burlap reese's
rash taught me shirt off with ruffles
that the members of the spring court
time the sites in the suspension the
social it i never upload this
indeed that was a federation and
suggested your sister because he stef wzsw
were in the operation of she should
respect second refer to the cypriot
and and exactly taxi drivers this part is
a few
with your photo 2 boxes of quotes
boot de built or pencil change
mozzarella and the meter off oil companies
talks blades in it post by red chilled
smooth would you like to see this
setting aside kees
consent april gets the shaft runny
kanye they go right in on epic
fairings of
this baladeo christie him in it
experts in the field of international
p  atroon arbitration de abc plus and
extensive lives and an exceptional edge
of case for our shop by their af at a2
b1 time and now all that porn
party beg generous they have not left a
single argument of russian federation
models consideration and they decide
the russian  federation
by taking a from a Vader taxation and
collection with their vision of yukos de
liberty a the encryption of us are doing
some
xprize xvi was investments and russian
federation is a warning to access this
decision
and is faring of range weapons and rush
after which the by  sth insurance agency
scorpio so the positive oh man that you tweeze
your partner who lie or excellent
researcher the idea that is we help so and
yet so in her direction clothing you
rubio critical both the decision of
the larger penis x absolutely
well considered and well reason  chargement
die filings to the coffee pajama
lily leaked and famicom principle the
russian federation this lotus class or
share the center  home but at home to
occasions how her owners and more
about elephant parade russian federation
it's like this lecture tension of the
often state the short period
give a correct and maurice en
chargement in a circus ipad is t
russian federation canadian and i
planned themselves in sets  which is not a baby
successfully test is primrose ogd
professional design one the
suspension sitchin in a moment between
the the conversation
new tactic
thank you and next to the walibi opportunity
for brief researcher to contacts my
tail rubber agence other know what free
listing 2013 managers dat sufficient
presses  mix reception expensive can you have
my show have now with better ok
who can through coaching
in the lap him with reply and find a
new locations of duffelen before the start
[Music]
[Music  ]
on
[Music]
do
oh
[Music]
but
minus
[Music]
[  Music]
yes she was
oh my god
yes
[Music]
monkeys sitting
place decide who could hear silent friends
vest en east west and birth by
your request we the professor hairdresser in
was allowed to speak
with this only older it is now armistice
day after your reply reprimand full of
those cards parsi speaks is dancer
sorry
you guys here ok
or us air force and red end in london
vlogs
the circle stands
anna bool members about god is nice epke
channel hobb  y letter or so from the
respect fat
there is a it it the drab abby smith
it will wrap gloss ever point values
ou buy points there would like to highl
ght the f
rst point road to make is let it box m
nute rico south about clothes notes the c
asps  can a
in a case where apps like me do that
thing how to upload those charts sation thats
the process my 2d and libie mansion and
one x apples russian federation
has already and the tumblr occasions
syndicate know where this country
tricias a hall professional
that  you yourself de beek analysis each time de
was a federation
with a clear time medicare in it
wasps dispute
have to be put to de always opted for
shampoo have time of the discussion in
the parliament and professor comfort en x
play at cordys x is it my hiss  and to
know
russian and lows reflections on a
lace party always think the double bass and
times shampoo adam lambert and or the
clothes nose
that your verdi seven for see on and for
15 volts it state  ment signs incorrect
and iphone youtube de mare document
site within the defense an appeal
paragraph of you one two three and en
check enzo's leandre quinty stacks of
documents
wish you where all this place has been a for
so and my argument no
military lines on the limitation  close
with before further and older traces
rejection the case with the this trick or
treat exodus auckland and the cord repeal
and that dessert lay this completely opens
a parasol etc te the co2 pio is dead
commission came so in adwords
this is new itself an issue
the  second point that lexie make
rica
so i not in language introduction about
maharbal to the opportunities site has
m set is so that the tennis lessons
wash this case an everyday versions the
russian federation this is the most
played and photo went and called
question  with it such a dispute
oh is that possible by the
protection of the treaty
then rode in the cat parties clothes
state parties
they puzzle ie al e  and growing cake the
core cpu
popoli interprets the text
the cake is door at freddy's intention
of the position is in this case in
the south asia possessions
he is be present at loudly and clearly a
few gardens to the fat moose brown 7
cassation
de hal jars  is let the kohlrabi io
continue pc that intrinsic opinion or the
investment together' and you get the code
many door
if you look a paraffin you can see
the cost per club psv separate definition
the first sentence in your mess round
slides fbi
big fan saint  the circuit chinese
capable efficient
add question was expression be
cheering that
hering in coming showcase had the court
of justice
and the old always en présenté par lamps
allegory latif you look at tesla
sandwiches
de slideshow off the site investment
refers to and investment and otherwise
the  definition links suddenly and is an
ideal area of the state links up to th
intrinsic opinion about language in west
ou can constant cover a ga
an books that genome x what is will
bring you agree to refuse and there is a
special hospital sittard warm in the
cell universe citizenship
ms sharepoint you can sense that
intrinsic beauty of a time and within
the commission
literally site there also contacts
basic upgrade data interpretation
6  the standard for whom interpretation or
who I see sting tracy text such an auto
gaba people duty
with a red listing treaty texts
well who castaert
cloud you will surely
exactly is kees annies marriage and
access it thank you for champion
neurological it was a fresh
catharina
think  you from apple jefferson who relay
exactly what you the ip address
you shorter d for whom choclade and just 5
so him in a celle minus him except
my office in the cell
the ordinary formal our to the g to day
because this gate and kees i  'm sorry i you
we en they
en elizabeth russian federation this
they can count on some
pimpa look in my countries
pink accused of differen  t ingress
affections are dan compliance we de
standish of de libero weston die mocro's
elm en for sure this case note about
their teeth never at all politics of
emotions is kees about their fundamental
legal syncs with google reshape him
dutch and international office manager
is to come and  the he hopes is your code
lives for long politics also
considerations and roll' focus oil on
the left blue which were presented by
the counsels
but i was briefly in the motor and
case is that swan is for jules said
trichet this season knowing german
politics  school change over time the
specials website but legal Prinsenbos
remain unchanged
de clemens mark wassink you to dismiss
alle kamp land in this way we like to
ask you to punish ratio for some things
but they both with cold wil job is
not just about was in staff  really
use case this approach will be fooled by
hundreds of two pianos in different
cases
nederlands radio op 1 juni and cancer
schoolby  are
your tip lucas case is never just the
logic is in the yesterday or international
rationem is a real life case that you
with wil with you of the paint use of
investments arbitration at the end of
this season this field habit
penza men for this future international
bettwäsche  we icecube
budget de clemens fonkel claims seth doe
struct coding 2000 and sixteens
subscribers and feared number of loss already
in the store brown's and not show
parties and adventure and always this i they
can derive for pyland
investments arbitration he lives outside
you by repeating kool  government our and
nuts specialist in germany go
again coming together ten
minus tobiassen site red and
the practically international oh and cross
and love handles and represent rushing
coffee grinders and the on the internet shop for
a stand our but frankly when 1000
liters be very  experienced lore
the west valley gio women liege hatch
a hashtag client and the stan
double we for  the reasonable rode still in
my and first for sure that the month
climbers the masses not just the legal dlc
moral
cost the claims within physiology nails
have oil than just in rhys and even
twice for the
for the youth face time when the
nineties t is it  was mattered why the
jokers for pinas
using offroad bradberry second time was
in early twenties one early next web to
be lens of us dose of the kampina de
winter by the fit time and as kink
youtube red
50 cm buttocks us dose en up recent en
president and samsung'
the priming minecraft moment of cut
them sorry for healthcare
for the social bennis and warm and to
protection and earth becoming obligations
youtube and ga serves a family a
surprise citizens
the pin code convention unanimously his
decision 2011 and icann can families  is
the agence in the code dead jokers words
it thumbs up to two discrimination
you it now self-titled never politicaly
prosecuted and became was a government
no we just have something  powers to
destroy the camps nancy's it s'en
scale we your pin code of human rights can
from became it was the jokers command
you must use the legal schemes for tax
evasion and circle that climb sorry
you have using the right to school
chair international cuisine en  tot de
dutch course and for short download real
life or in a western
and this fancy tunnel was fantastic
bibi cream
was a branch face using coffeeshop
companies and russia was a becoming a
would-be deal with cold is kees
chodorkovsky navel in a surprise
yukos  oligarchs gins wash but nobody
news real in the takes about the claim
the campus full will clements to my
talent that this case was decided
and the d claims to reject it many years
ago incompetent russian coaching
clothing supreme commercial cord and
costs
such a short about  are according to irish
clemont very much seafight and we dance
newbie who deceives arbitration
chipiona and german coach
family and this stuff impotent argum  ent
that was an epcot center of the
competence of internet lamp it rational
this case and the and adjusted self
provider
it out orly de kan this social
assistant money laundering logo the beat up like
professional and washing positional
code wansink a switch small december
2000 and trend that  i game can find that
russia coronary pro vision led light
arbitration crisis in an analogy fight
to reach ssd inconsistent wardrobe
system mother was a constructive and
he must i a fan this object is though was
a bit switch
can you need fda buticosus a website and
the  ole ole
agreement which was not at red verte was
there now to estimate
lose l'application du tweety in de
respect be the horse or so willie
white noise ratio is clearly
set cost such a coach several times but
also find the fundamental principles of
zo  for energies
the separation of powers the mocro's
earlier about lorent
online elekt the parliament cam die
concepts de tradition of international
champi  on of the speed of sound right
from the crib pink a blade of your
eyes of european constitution center
variations of the look af en states and
otherwise there no difference between
the provision application and dried
treats de spy perfect berlin jakarta
this yourself can be your provider for  the
certification to come into force en is
such a graphite what I parliament or so it
was the new long before this case
white rabbit racing
it was now a the russian parliament
rejected the ratification trot loyal file
better by the government to wear to be
determined moment  will de and adjusted to
right i was not what you fight en de de
parliament rejected your advice in the
end of line this respect i just before
making this very important decision your
an indian crash a role in settle
arbitration wheel is it was want
design to  be de predictable and the
independent mekka nismo dispute
resolution
and protecting ge of jean en
international investments en de meent in
westers  e made by bona fide investors
how many fish can they take with them the
rule of law democracy and separation of
powers principle sorry will teach will be kamp
instrument of promotion of great
corruption and political scientist james en
Veel international treaties been capita die
railing good 5 en in according to  the
true wheel of something against a chaise-en
for sure if you have any doubt about
interpretation of energy talent to our
shop is a portal crash en smash bros
or further away requested to show their
way as catering further questions to ben
en luxeboek hoor  he polite you
make up fact dc so good stuff bing
compliance with the day
european international cross and do and
els between zurich hope it's kees
how lettuce fascinates my state pension finally come
play button my 5th prize for your
pension ok thanks can now
decorate that  to kill
i only saw the grade less mind
you then i look at mall and then it went at
the end of february
thank you
festivalitis van tj touc  h yo coaches b
in east send the site in accordance with
de loo and then two bears sandwiches with
rings like it legal in my role
appeared and follow reverence
in a song proper scale readily
de euro activations the russian
federation and becomes lychee carriage my
family in d'ardoye deceptive
what degree is the dumas
rejection de ict in education or
gruesome in the file or i finally got a
wonderful slide about the head workflow
structure and free wi-fi is a a
project
suggestion of that tight traditional
abstract is a  very simple to find it
in the interests of the quay bional
streams there her are at he
sancho van de screen this is x i ran
acts
based on information or less made
available by myself to now in
star city
the russian federation games you and
structure
met mg  boxing senggigi side erotic
peridot the way around
the effect city themes free much more
sensible
en in the rai q7 themselves driver driver
polymax
home you have this wor  ld applause
here and there is what was serious pikenier
dictation the information on which i base
joris alsace pinot shirt die here if there is
to the products russian federation about
the stick on his plan and age free wired
self now lesson bit it is india be crazy
but  also
there is that on black ash and for criminal
prosecution take that is inside
cheers shirt the white diamonds a red
blood and wolff human within the duration
mudface when most silent in the
dumas and member flash instructions that
has still at large a teahouse seriously
week and who doesn't
the often that he cut that speculaas
the song gripes men pas two miles and
the french
breeding net a number for teaching you
find school
argument bout the international walk with
chic of the united nations to the
contributions of germany and the
netherlands there  too but their legal
since and some very different today
of russia on which  jn
commission et internationaux role of the
russian federation aan it simply home
dividend measures of the russian-english
en en provisions der of
patch chicken kop is a self in the
code traffic he must be very
very quickly and so pleading notes was
very wisent  judgment of the ga you score
well this is the
[ __ ] constitutional goodwitch published
21 December 5 last of peak oil
target difference christmas card with and the
where you look at what a really happened
and perhaps you work will let you colic
software in the suspension
decision rescue question to  the russian
federation whether i could actually have
made its legal obligations of my life
and mr meijer set from brescia
following
french how die led by het syntra school
this christmas time and clearly shows
how back in federation
is can you buy this in science at
intres  we stuck in response to the
chorophyl station in this case in the
less this content you seen on the act
to the constitution agree
so that exactly can be conducted notepad
behind closed doors and then the for the
consumer as the costs add sweets
to clarify god my tongue g-football
surprise discussion things that is render
t who is the euro and a minuit the
new captain crunch that skin and that  en
in a great space on this post
complied with this request and miss van
de berg and the god she touch it is the
polder also for men he chorophyl
reasoning regarding
machinaal  vpl scotch
magic is miles it is cumbersome
but number happy' necessary least
densely that my send you riley in
line with russian governments previously
en downs liner task and response de the
final touch him and indes present case in
any event the christmas card my is there
effective and i ran off a cd shop you
the final touch people the hive appeal
needed blood adenine retrofit and sugar
i ran it is bion the ships those
papers in cash juleske fine by
initiating document file ykes ii i would
brad pitt a second adaptation of
russian york canape test kits in kcna en
noor is magic christmas card mens
revolt er not correct with letters
explain this in a zipper and
reply and finally done let's face it
the brooch a constitutional  court or
at ihc track record de tent mee vol de
russian federation die critique in terms of
design legal base is the substantial
something refusal to combine this
international legal obligations in
yokocho nature critical and kick off the
european court of human rights rendert
something 2014 judgment in yukos oil de
russian federation and the
pasta drock legislation at such
chargement scampi's gadget review by the
same concertation code and this is still we
standing leftovers legal obligations under
the sea your heart i a blog with the guard
mens er the coach and the russian
constitutional corendon  to this site as
desired
the thumb jackman constitution violation of
the russian constitution perfect at the
unique  pj sum of money and
more equally well not be enforced witches
a flickering
and ever en violation of leftovers criticism
of league actions at large a bodyguard
with a and letter feedback to my
colleague mr chica booty with the chinook
soviets
if you can for  insights from sorry
wil goldsmith nou in the first place in
the first round and with extensive drew
certain salami
criteria anaphora hyperfleece smg more
about this b&b sat left in white great
pics neater from your sketch me miracoli
ec2 biologist george
under your name is lee posterous  his
word as the decision of the code for
piel is that no additional
requirements should be right into one x
and one seven to the pointers the salami
criteria here is that decubal chargement
in the context of the interpretation of
the xx critique en de koek en de  france
is what generally it's not likely that
judgments outside the frame rate would be
leading hip this is the mug
authentic the xe treaty retina could be  and snow
definition of investments and specifically
the babies die bianca wingweb which for
the ict which does have split neck
definition of investor investments
and and that's normal events and say
zoom in philosophy that is also looks into
my second point about the mojo via
bottles scrum sprinkle  case reset hering
en luxe bike wear the cherry pick from
judgment of parties in the preceding
will also link to parties in dus
souling set set and ensure you
understand is budget
in advance is action that succeeded
charms is kate is a broken is more
importantly do is that we must think and
feel i would not much is the construction
english this is more than you need an
show
you now know the judicial decisions of typical
ine the background  of the case and
must be facts in the case
what is facts
party now come striping the
a sign of for contract energy supplies
and dutch so the livery is broken  place from
ukraine
om de boats or modave via and in that
context the question rose
we have that was an investments in
opinions
article of juice sex pots and ribéry in
kop stayed finds kees tandem action before
you today crown it is evident
that davy  was
contentious
we 6 6 in a rush a camp in our hands
so marquis or once every two of
acrylic super 2 3 different parts of
article by sabo-fx where is the cheese in the
matter for study and soup
there is the role for whom implication  dat
de ark line to hang on to questions at
war as in a method totally different
angles background distress relating to
whether the shares of age 4 ice it
for the
dat définition en letty den pants german
you dat if the code for bio on this
cute  chili and cheese asian sex parties
agree that the session of the russian
federation find no support in the
language of the provision you must snot
misslady more different interprétation
it simply be a traffic light
is a stable effec  t dat the logs
of the vision games no reason to follow
the interprétation da freak out now two
things done
finally on this is now i'm sorry let me
kom ik en he has u beautiful and swipe
[ __ ] is in response 2 wat professor
ghoul pair  hands
get out about the bit medicine man on the
things at this time arbitration
is in breeze wario aan this is our
color of the money but she says that
were always
of search to for education second
goalkeeper
when that this is an argument that is
my race white  russian federation the
course appeal responded to this sense and
brand is en lammy coat and car finding
and it's a touch with this is to go
further but they are four seven fifty
five en vol 750 6 and the code vpl [ __ ]
and sentences conclusion
i closed the
juliet de the view that such a big try
and is in breach of was a [ __ ] tot
decision adp had to be ratified pike's there and international investments arbitration had been agreed  and is correct has
completely further appeared a substantial
chad and raising danny like a nut
speech in cassation of the final point is
to duet with mister cash at once i just
shake that in a first round many in
action russian we good for and that so the
triggers' with your phone more about
did
we would you prefer to was a patch
about things
presented and the door ma
communicate is in the dumas
but in the end the final conclusion where
the badge
was or too long hair sign buy nathan's
the various things that  mr van care
choirmaster you quickly and the conclusion that
the boy was there already our corinth the
door with the provisions of the ict of
compatible bins
consistent with russian [ __ ] since
in the report of the feeling of the door
but i was something in the provisions  of
the ict and send chili comply with the
provisions of nu
russian language is a significant
supplementing en renner die sites more
precise buy online
ibood prefer youtube de pineut
bleeding subtle and the moanings en of 20
September 3, 2010
clothes nose and the politicians my under
number one 100 and aids in a country
nineteen aan in wat nineteen great but
maybe this story to which mr verkerk
plus preferred
is oil have  from the comment nike nike
seven by profession the bistro focus
notes my brother mah ni-mh was a skate
booty and his position was that the
russian federation
listen us about a two and how the
music is it is international
arbitration and this parties politics
or bizarre  ability and has nothing to do
with legal conflict between the ict
answer lolo in art and cbd death of
the tribe there full of
what the current position or door
agree and and whether the states that many times
possibly that there was in fact now in
consistency
thank you thank you between president and this
brings study end of this year in a row
your great with you that she would send
is a zipper and
reply other join the by
five mark to briefly af te  throw what
takes your time for the opinion of the
lawyer john already off which will be
given the opportunity for en citizens
letter a and f ink in the garden furniture
jets another four weeks
they complication mass and then yours
garden and the course  you can assure you
that how you will if everything was great more
accurate
aan caesar cm zo mike lens mr i
thank you for coming thank you for being
presenting you die en safe journey
[Music]
oh